okay hello everyone we are here to do a
wol language design review about
language human language that
is so or maybe it's also wolf
malfa let's should we start off with
fanatic
symbols I think that's probably a good
place this was a thing that we we had
talked about we didn't have anything
really to look at last time Christian
has put in a very very preliminary
packet with some properties
um I think it's it's just going to be
more helpful for us to kind of look at
this early on and figure out what we
want to do with it think about naming of
things and how they're going to be
useful this is focus sort of alpha
forward but we also are going to want
these things in the language
okay so I
mean obviously those shouldn't be
capitalized but right yeah that's lots
of design things and capitalization of
values that we need to fix but there's
some so I thought that with fonetic I
mean there are all these things
about um the classification of the thing
I guess
that's and then there's also you know
what the mouth shape is for that and so
on right Manner and place of
articulation and those kinds of things
yeah right and then
um
but I think I
mean this
entity is something that for example
from a we're supposed to have a
classifier that will go
from
a you know a a
waveform to break it into phones right
that was one of the things that was
supposed to be coming from
the audio team right and so then one of
the questions is but my I mean my
assumption is what that will output is
just uh string IP a string of IPA
symbols right I think so I think it's
basically like just like we will have
spe we have speech recognized that gives
us
words this will be I mean perhaps we
should put it into speech
recognize with a second argument or
something that says phonetic or
something like that that just gives the
phonemes
yeah um then there's the question of can
we go from the phones to the to the
words right and yeah
well you know or maybe we need a thing
that is something like um you know
phonetic
uh I don't know whether phonetic form is
quite the right thing that could take
you know
elephant and
that I mean could either take that or it
could take
audio but either way what it's doing is
I mean I don't know if I say word
data um
elephant and then I say right I mean we
have a I can't
the
yeah
okay so is that but then that would be I
mean to go phonetic form of a string is
going to be dependent on
us
having having a stored IPA
representation of a word in a given
language or are you imagining okay right
but this is what what should happen is
if we say speech synthesiz m
of
elephant
then okay now we say now I'm imagining
does that actually do right now I'm just
realizing I don't know what it is is
does beep synthesize go from anything
we've got stored or is that that's
machine learning stuff to do that's
machine learning go from the words it
has nothing to do with the phonetic form
oh
dear that's unfortunate we should give
that to
the got machine learning and audio teams
it's a good test and QA it's a good test
to do the round trip the speech and
speech recognize I mean it's very
hard but we can imagine taking that that
speech form and saying fonetic form of
that or phonetic you know maybe
I don't know if it's speech
recognize you know I don't know whether
uh Speech recognize should take a second
argument which
says um yeah I think it could just um
literally take a second argument that
just says
fanatic maybe that's the right thing but
I'm not quite sure what this should
do
um
I'm not sure but something why would
that yeah why why is that
more uh uncertain than the phonetic form
of a
string um hold on a
second where are we putting
this I don't think you had saved a
notebook last time do we have a word
data could
let's cool this word I you you had a
word data down below but yeah that
works okay what were you saying I was
saying why why is phonetic form of
audio less certain for you than phonetic
form of a
string oh
because this I I like the recognized
word because it's much less clear that
you can do it oh I got it okay you mean
just the naming of the okay yeah got it
okay but but then once we have
this you know I don't even know I don't
know what that what that means I don't
know what you know for each of these
letters I mean it's sort of interesting
because what we want to do here if I say
characters repr present
okay we we have you know a two entity
concept
right which right now is just characters
you're thinking that could be going to
the recognizing those as phonetic
symbols and giving you things that would
have the phonetic properties I think
that would be the first yeah
interpretation for the string
yeah except that here that just says
Latin small letter F so that's super
confusing so in the phonetic form here
surely Unicode has in it all the fanatic
you know that's just an F it's not a
it's not some kind of fanatic
f is I mean I don't know if I don't
recall off hand is there
a specific F to IPA or does IPA use I
don't know Latin
characters does anybody Francisco or
Christian do you guys know off hand I
mean uh if you see the example in the
scanner uh down below you can see that
for example that symbol is what we would
call like an i and it's a close from
unrouted bowel so I believe there are
some characters that will be represented
as
bowels as you know
letters no look at that that's not right
look at that see that that's the unic
code for a standard communal Garden
eye so I'm saying that's not a special
eye in some kind of special part of unic
code space
right that's that's what I'm thinking
that that
IPA is some regular Latin symbols plus
like the you know the schah symbol it's
that's used for things it's not unique
to
IPA yes well
so okay so that's telling us
that arguably even this phonetic form
isn't quite right although we probably
used it in other places so we have we'll
need to have a different name for that
we'll need something which
is
the true IPA string
here which okay you know it's making me
think that we need some
rapper I don't know I don't know if this
is right I mean you know that that
says oh I don't know I mean okay so what
functions are we going to have we're
going to have I mean um we when you
represent something phonetically you
usually have the string you usually have
it between back slashes or slashes or in
Brackets so if the string had that we
would say that uh string wrapper you
could try to recognize those and those
characters as fonetic
symbols okay I mean
so that's a good point what's yeah it's
a good point yeah I mean so you're
saying
I mean we could what what do you think
the Unicode is for that backslash maybe
there's a special Unicode for that and
we could just literally parse the thing
into
that I'm not even sure it's the special
kind of backslash I think it's just the
that that the yeah see a SE a sequence
of characters that happen to be in the
family of things that are used in
IPA are presented between two
backslashes and of things that that
together says oh that's that's
pronunciation yeah it's just a
convention basically I understand that
but if we wanted
to we could end up with some actual
character that we've invented that is
you know some is that a raw backslash I
don't know what is that no that's just
an ordinary backslash yeah okay I
mean okay what is one going to be using
this for
um hold on
SEC
um
[Music]
um uh
okay um
let's see what are we doing here
uh I mean the question
okay we want to be able to
go I mean what operations do we want
think we want to
do
on fanatic strings
you know we might want to do let's let's
make a list of some
operations okay so we want to go
audio to
fonetic fonetic to
audio we might want to do things like
like uh language or accent
recognize
um we might want to
create
um create diagrams for how to say a
word see what I'm
saying um or you know create a
video
um okay what El you're talking about
using the thing like the
the
uh side view of the whole yeah yeah
right language apparatus yeah
yeah
um I'm trying to remember I mean if I
pick a book about phonetics off my shelf
and I have at least one I mean what's
going to be in
it
[Music]
um I'm going to do the experiment just a
second
it shows that the stuff about language
is actually active in my world because I
have these books nearby I have three of
them here practical introduction to
Fanatics okay
so ah Cardinal vowels so that they
diagrams of um
uh
[Music]
um yeah they're all kinds of stuff about
um sort
of it's it's a lot about kind of how the
translation between the
physicality of air motion and things
and
uh oh and there things about transitions
from one vow you know from one phoni to
another those types of
things
MH first and second formance of the
Cardinal
vowels
uh yeah okay and then there's there's
all the tonal stuff for you know
languages like
Chinese
um all right
I have a thicker book
here it says more because it's thicker
lot of stuff about yeah there's a a lot
of stuff here about
waveforms
um I see things with different vowel
systems for different okay so there's
the other one is the mapping from
language to phones MH that's
another that's another type of
thing uh I mean it's also interex I know
you were you were looking for vowels and
consonants over the weekend I wasn't
sure what the context of that was but
that that brought up some of the
old if we're talking about English
that's pretty straightforward as soon as
we get away from English it it can get
more complicated but we hadn't really
been the last time we looked at it
seriously we weren't really thinking
about phones and thinking about vowels
not as just you know this collection of
of written characters in a language that
represent these things but it's it
sounds and so that's that's something
that I think we can address
here right oh there's rhyming stuff and
so
on
yeah
uh okay all right well I mean I
think I think the most basic thing is
just you know
getting I don't know whether
um right I mean look we clearly got some
distance here we've got to have entities
in the language that represent all the
pieces of IPA we've got to have entity
classes for you know La bills and things
like this all the usual
stuff right we got part of the way there
10 years ago let's finish
it at least for now we're all of the
different symbols that mean something in
I and the other thing we touched on
before is that some of some of the
symbols are diacritics right they're
they are things that need to be paired
with some other symbol and they modify
it in some way but in any but in any
case I don't know the set of the set of
standard properties
about Place manner of articulation
backness height all these different
properties that
describe specific
sounds sort of there are I think like
Christian do you I don't know if you had
looked at this do we are there kind of
clear mappings
for what phon names are are commonly
used or or not used in particular
languages do we have that mapping
between we certainly can get that that's
a thing can get that uh I believe from
the specific Wikipedia pages of the of
each of the symbols there's a section
called occurrences if I'm not mistaken
well you can also go to to you know
dictionaries yeah go and figure out I
think it be a good thing to do to get
the frequencies of different phones in
in certain languages
MH okay
okay
um you know in English there are weird
phones that occur but very rarely MH I
think
um okay what else do we have to look at
with this right now I mean so so clearly
in this thing we're going to want to see
the stylized for a vowel for example we
want to see the stylized
performance that um
this corresponds to we're going to need
to have uh certainly in the
language something represented in terms
of audio
generators that makes that phon we want
to have the kind of the standard you
were talking about the
um oh what was it the Cardinal vowels
and there's there's that kind of
standard table of vowels yeah you want
to be able to generate the we need the
standard graphic in some way that we can
highlight where things sit in relation
to other
symbols right I think for wol
malfa that's exactly what we need to do
we need to be able to show where in that
diagram you know in the standard diagram
this particular object
occurs that make sense
yeah okay all right should we go on yeah
I think
so uh language language family this was
we had touched we mostly had just looked
at this classification pod because um
Christian was updating that uh last time
the you had some comments about the
layout of that he's implemented some of
those changes so I think we wanted to
just take a look at design and pod and
there in the language is it a
tree uh sorry no it is not a Tre is a
graph because we have
three is implemented is not yet
implemented in
12 okay but but it should be
in when we make this an entity in the
language it should return a
tree
right okay sure that can be done right
what it what it does right now
implementation internal to of malfa is
not so
relevant um I mean this look a lot
better
yeah
it's
cool oh boy we need the is the sorry can
you can you go up is the the um the
handling of cases when we have many many
many siblings at a given level is that
you should do it the way trees do it I
mean you know it's a temporary thing
that we're doing well this is more or
less how trees do it okay yeah yeah
that's how we're doing it the the gray
blob is basically the Elion the
equivalent of an Elion blob in the tree
that's fine and eventually these should
just be trees
yes um you should be able to get the
tree in the language yes saap yes okay
now if I look at these intermediate
languages Latino F
fisan do we have properties for
that I all of these are entities aren't
they Christian they're either langu
these are those are families right yes
those are families and we do have
properties for those but the backet
itself is still on Def mod it's it's not
yet in
production I see so if I go
Latino bisan here I'm not going to win
no okay I will in the future unless you
go in Death Mode and still uh we are
trying to add not all of the entities
has have Spellings yet and we're trying
to add that team appear that's open
right now PR sorry
um did I just learn some other languages
version
of um full request okay the the um uh
how many languages are there of these of
these sort of intermediate because I
mean these are not in the current
inventory and are we treating them as
different you know Western romance is is
a historical language right or no in
these cases they are language families
and they are not Languages by itself but
rather like grouping of languages if it
would be a way of saying
them
right okay but those entities are they
like our language entity I mean if I say
um you know if I have a language here
that's a language entity but something
like Western romance what is it going to
be is it what What entity type is it
going to be uh language family family
yeah okay do we already have that
it is in Death Mode that that's exactly
the thing that we're talking about oh I
see what you're saying what we what we
already language family is for the most
part things that previously were uh
entity classes in language data now what
the heck are we going to do with that uh
the plan right now is well the idea is
that when H we Implement language family
H those classes will well would not be
classes but instead would point to the
language family entity okay it seems to
make sense to me although it still might
be useful go ahead no no no I mean we
can we
can preserve but Downs score the entity
classes for some time I think but it's
it's much more useful to have them as
entities because they do have properties
themselves but specific properties but
what about the possibility of thinking
about them as hierarchical
entities I mean this is very similar to
well BM species
Etc isn't
it no because there's no there's no
like finite canonical set of levels here
like there's nothing in that graph on
the left that corresponds to Kingdom
right so we haven't had concept of of um
I mean for for this is a worth bringing
up with the hierarchical entity people
that I mean this is a case we haven't
seen before where as you say we don't
have
know meanings to different levels in the
tree yeah I
mean hierarchical entities work when
each you know each level is is going to
be a different entity type and this is
not this is just yeah I
understand a different relationship than
what that's meant to to
convey I understand although it sort of
reminds
me I see so if if we're thinking about
organization like an army it's got you
know I don't know what you know
divisions regiments whatever and each
one has a name each level each level has
a name yeah whereas here you claim that
this is a
pure sort of containment story without
names without names for the levels yeah
at at most you could have ER in the
language family you could differentiate
the ones that are root families and the
ones that aren't but that would be the
only hierarchical differentiation that
you could make all right okay I I
retract my thought that this so so I
think then
this it's an interesting case it is
worth pointing out to the hierarchal
folk that there is this case because
maybe there's a way that they could
handle
this um I worry a about that these names
are really
obscure you know Northwestern shifted
romance sounds like uh uh okay all right
but anyway all right this looks good so
what else let's see let look at language
family
properties right I mean this this is the
stuff that Christian was saying this is
still in Dev but just to be able to see
right now what's showing up in in the
language if we want to talk about
property
naming how things are represented
here well I mean this is sort of an
interesting
concept I mean to me if you can get out
the tree I mean one of the properties
should just
be
uh something
about
well I see so there's a single path from
the route to this particular thing and
the question is to generate the tree
that is kind of a
sibling type
tree boy I mean what you really want is
that tree and you want to know where
this particular language is in that
tree I'm and I mean you would you would
be able to see that in the three
property I believe it's in others I'm
not sure though uh yeah this ancestry
tree it's only really going to give you
a straight line of well I know I know I
know I understand that okay understand
but I mean so
somewhere I see there are disconnected
parts to the tree of all languages
because there are different roots for
different root families yes I see so you
can see the full tree for the root
family yeah that makes sense
I mean in the end we're going to want
something which gives all the root all
all those trees the
full
um is there a property Christian that
indicates whether something is a root
family or
not a class of entities that's root
families no it could be easily
implemented though I mean I believe
there is that's what you would want
right you that would if you would want
to be able to get all the root families
and show all the trees of that's what
you're saying I think Stephen sure that
would be implemented like a root family
classes a root family class sorry yes
yes
yes okay um yeah I do believe there is
like a root family Cube property and so
the glass would be use we we would just
have to use
that
I see okay so this is aggregating the
individual languages so I'm a little bit
unclear if somebody speaks
both you know English and
Welsh do they get double counted in I
don't know whether English and Welsh
come from the same root family let's
assume they do um do they get double
counted or not if I say What's the total
number of native speakers of um
uh whatever the root family well
Indo-European right if they speak
English and French and you're counting
the total number of indoeuropean
speakers do you correctly count them
only once between the English and
French uh no I do believe it would it
would be duplicated yes or how it's
implemented okay I don't know whether we
can do any better than
that
uh I mean that seems
the question is do does it make sense to
try to aggregate if we don't if we
can't know what's happening at the
individual language level it might not
make sense to do that right we should
best best just get the derived languages
from a language family so presumably one
of the properties here is languages in
that language
family where is
that I mean what are the what are
the leaves in under under that node yeah
you have descendant
languages okay okay that's and that
languages are that's not the families
that might be under a given family it's
following the branches all the way out
to the end those are all the things that
are out at the end of the branches I
mean these names are not obviously bad
but but they're just I mean I don't know
what the difference between number of
languages and number of descendants is
uh if the things that The Descendants
includes also the language families that
are under than particular but that's
confusing because it says descendant
languages of which the number of
languages is I mean this should probably
should just have a languages yeah fair
enough and this is
um I mean something this is more like
tree size or something like that or I
don't know what this is because that's
not what's children is that the number
of children who speak these languages I
don't think
so
uh what what is the difference between
is children children is children is
basically that's like the the list of
entities that corresponds to number of
descendants no children is the number of
number of descendants immediately below
like as if you were a parent and you
have children yes but your descendants
are the children of the children some
and go it doesn't include grandchildren
no it just includ the first
level look we have conventions for this
for trees we should use them I don't
know what they
are okay we've got names of functions
for this and so on let's base this
nomenclature on
that make sense okay
sure I think we're not far off from
that the children and
terminology there
too what is this all
about uh these were this is another big
set of properties that are in Dev mode
that are that are about language
structure this is all the stuff from the
World Almanac of language
structures um this this before was just
what the output was Christian has a PR
up that's fixing some of this we we
didn't like the property names I think
he's change this right Christian so that
you're using more directly the the way
that these things are are referred to in
walls yes um and also the the something
plus the plus as a separator is not
really conventional that's usually more
a dash to indicate those sequences think
it should be plus plus seems like it
could be in any order I think it's like
it's a dash more to indicate it goes BL
to blah to blah right that's that's what
I'm saying this is this is this is the
old version this is what we didn't like
last time there scroll down there's a
there's a oh I think a screenshot from
the pr that's right I think those dashes
should be bigger and probably we should
yeah condense those we don't need all
the white space
yeah that's
nice now things like subject object
subject verb object in in the language
anguage presumably that thing that
property will return a list subject verb
object and then that that was a that was
a there was a question I had is how how
we want to represent those in the
language like there for most of these
things there's a there's a there's a
finite set
of orders right that that exist in all
languages so like is subject verb object
is a specific thing that applies to a
bunch of different languages should that
itself be represented as an entity I
mean we do have a list of strings right
sorry we do sorry I'm
sorry we do have EP tables for
this and in those cases uh the value is
these are entities right so the entity
in this case would be I believe SBO
that's the standard name and and the
value would be at least as you said
what do you mean by the value as opposed
to The Entity I mean the
entity give me one second for
that
um well what I'm one thing is the thing
called subject here better be an entity
of some
type yeah so the entity would be s o for
SBO in this case but Stephen suggesting
breaking that decomposing that more
right you're suggesting that we would
return a list grammatical unit adjective
is a grammatical list is grammatical
unit what is
subject see what I'm saying so in that
order of adjective and
noun there's two possibilities either in
word order it's either
SVO or it's the list subject entity verb
entity object
entity okay yeah sure I believe it would
be better for it to be the list I think
it's more useful and more flexible yes
is would we consider
subject a um a grammatical unit I'm not
sure I was wondering the same thing I
got another we we don't we don't have
I'm just looking at the list of
grammatical units we have now and we
don't but we have we have weird things
in there it wouldn't be out of
place we have we have even more specific
things like passive nominal
subject huh noun phrase as an adverbial
modifier so straightforward things like
subject object would not be out of
place
okay noun Pres
plural huh no I mean I think that do you
remember Ben I I want to say that this
list was this was all the things that
grammatical structure could return and
so we anied all the things that could
show up in you mean text structure or
text structure that's it yeah yeah that
sounds familiar but I couldn't say for
sure yeah so now that I'm checking the
code when I mention the value is a list
uh so the standard name is is Boo in
this case but probably not the best name
but we have a property called value
which G of strings yeah
yeah look one thing I'm concerned about
is there are languages that have
undefined word order and I don't think
we want to have a list of all the
permutations of subject verb
object I mean that could be a missing
undefined order or something could be a
if it's if it's really not relevant we
can have a custom missing or some other
um yeah for these cases uh in the EP
tables the the value would be a stream
that says there's no dominant no
dominant
order well we can't do that it's got to
be something more computable it could be
a missing not
applicable not not applicable it would
be a specific missing it would be a
missing you know no defined order or
something no dominant order maybe yeah
but but are there languages in which
it's you know SBO or vso but not
osv or is it the case that there's
either a defined or word order and it's
blah or there's no defined word order
good
question I that's an easy question to
answer by looking at one of these
atlases yeah
isn't Latin fairly flexible about word
order not when I learned it it wasn't it
was always ver
end but I think it I think I think in oh
I think it's changed a lot since
then
the no I mean I think it probably the
Poetry probably works differently but
um I mean there certainly are languages
where the word order is undefined and
where there are decorators on the words
[Music]
mhm um some language I was reading about
recently some indigenous Australian
language that has some even more
exotic
mechanism but uh okay so look I think
okay provisionally let's determine the
answer to that question is it either
determined or completely under
determined I think we might have to I'm
just I'm looking at walls right now I we
might have to I think we have to do a
little more manual work I'm I'm I'm
thinking that the the classifications in
walls May really be expressing that
there's a dominant order there could be
there could be exceptions in many
languages but
whatl for S I mean if you go Yoda speak
you you're going out of the standard
order right I believe if you open the
word order subtitle maybe there could be
there what unique values we
have yeah so those are the values that
we we have right for that's that's what
I'm saying is that's what comes out of
walls but that doesn't mean that it's
not possible to have a different that
that a different order wouldn't be valid
in some cases in that language just
means this is the
dominant uh order for a given
language kind of interesting it
is so all the orders used by somebody
osv is used by Klingon and maybe a few
actual
languages unless all of them turn out to
bees are you serious OSB yeah OSB is is
is in the klling on con line okay it's
an OSB
language I think there was a whole
backstory to
that
um I don't know whether I think there
are some natural well maybe three
natural
languages
um
h i mean it is sort of useful to be able
to just see these things as osv s so etc
etc etc
MH
look maybe we could
say we could have a property name that's
like word order
type and then another one called word
order
list see what I'm saying word order type
would be the
entity SVO for example yeah yeah word
order list is the grammatical
units and we could follow that principle
for some of these other ones where we
don't necessarily want to have an a
sequence I don't know what these
are see I don't know what the hell those
are but this is looking a lot more
like oh yeah I mean this is not well
represented whatever obligatory double
negation is
really the only way to make a positive
statement is to make a notot
statement it's
interesting yeah I believe there there
must be some definitions that below so
maybe there's more explanation for
that no it's just no no no in oh no in
the table I believe it's a second
table well that's different I mean
double negation means something very
different I mean in logic it means you
know not not p and law of excluded
middle that means
P I was thinking you were telling me
there were languages where in order to
say yes you have to say no
no interesting
idea
indeed
um
well I I'm thinking from this that we're
going to have to have
[Music]
named features and we can have for this
particular case which is really common
we can have another property which is
the string which is the listify version
of
this see what I'm
saying yes I mean that could also that
that could also be a property of the
entity yeah uh as I mentioned to go one
more step but that that could be clean
yeah you have the thing you call Value
right now yeah probably a better name a
Better Property name but it already
exists fair enough well we can go with
that for now
yeah right and there there are various
other ones that could be represented the
same way the entities could return a
list of other grammatical units things
yeah but I mean these names like
adjective and noun that's not a good
name I mean it should be something like
adjecti adjectival order or something
I think these these things I think I
think also Christian I mean you you've
been fixing the display names in the
scanner I think we might also want to
update some of the the standard names of
some of the properties too because they
they are also a little sure yeah more
tur than they they should be they'll be
confusing in the language yeah it would
be good to have something that's say
more read
up I see on our live stream at
mentioning that in tent which I'm
guessing might be a language spoken in
in TR and Netherlands I have no idea
that joah joa which I'm pronouncing and
no doubt with totally the wrong phon
names is a yes yes which means
no it's a famous
story well at least uh
of some I think it was some philosopher
in Oxford who was a uh giving some talk
about how you know double negation is an
affirmative but
that you know that that any number of
affirmatives always means affirmative so
to
speak and somebody immediately says
Yaya which of course is a counter
example like this one because
Yaya is means no I don't believe
you
so language is complicated yeah yeah
that have to do more with the intonation
that the or the gadance yes that's
true all right so we've got lots of
properties here and probably a bunch of
property names which have you guys gone
through these property names in detail
or not I I think we need to go through
them again it's been a while since we
looked closely at them yeah this is
weird 8 to nine it's it's um
any those that's how that's how walls
divides them right they have they have
some strange bins
sometimes boy what a weird thing 6 OR7
grammatical cases is the most common B
from
zero W I mean it's also a good question
of you know does is this a property for
which we need to have an entity property
table assigned or should we should we
just be
returning you know zero interval
667 I think we should probably rning
like blah blah these these could be
other wolfin language structures and
not grammatical
cases you know zero or
whatever
yeah
um there's not much more you can say
about those entities themselves because
they do just represent some numerical
bin
right this is I was looking at this
because you were asking again this is
you know their numbers their intervals
of things that's weird that walls
doesn't give us um
V and consant inventories but again
these are things that we can we can get
from we should find these I mean I don't
know why classifying them this
way seems I mean it's it's it's what
they do I mean they're they're not
they're not they're just trying to
return their standard set of however for
many dozens of properties and different
categorical
things they do have a lot of references
to other resources for all these
languages too though so dictionaries and
papers and other things that have more
detailed data for some of these things
that we want to pick
up yeah moderately large cons inventory
is not terribly useful to
us I mean look even in English there's
some fuzziness like with why and things
like
this
yeah but I
think
yeah I mean it also will be the case
that if we can get what the actual
consonants are in these languages that
would be super useful right uh I believe
it would be useful but we also would
have to consider that I I believe the
reason why it's like a wrench and not a
set number is because it's it kind of
has variations depending of where the
language is spoken for example
well could also be that you know some I
don't know why in English I don't think
is often thought of as a consonant but I
don't know whether
it's think we need something where well
we should see what people have done in
terms of saying some things like you
know m is
uncontroversially a consonant in English
and a is uncontroversially
AOW and then there are more obscure
cases like why for
example and maybe we can have
semivowels I don't know I mean maybe
there I mean it's a term that gets used
sometimes okay well then that's a good
thing I
mean I'm thinking in in
uh I'm not sure we've had that case very
often of there are three possibilities
and things are definitively a
definitively b
or it's unclear
MH all right let's just take a quick
look at some of these other things yeah
I that's what I was going to ask do you
we could schedule
another follow up and and get into this
because there's a lot here that's about
um it TI I mean it ties in with the word
list harmonization and how we want to
deal with the fact that we have
different word lists with you know
different amounts of coverage of
inflections and plurals and other things
and do we really want do we want an
entity for every possible inflected form
of everything if we don't then how do we
represent those things in all the
different places that we're storing
them I wanted to ask I mean I see in the
the sdl meetings that you're coming up
with
a some new form representing
actions and and some of these other
things they're not words they're other
things and that's I'm I'm wondering if
there's some some other in between
thing that we want to be thinking about
with this like the notion of a decorator
function for a word that says this is
the the plural of X this is
the
whatever something of something look
what we're going to do is we're going to
have words which are things said in
languages and then we're going to have
Concepts concept like things which
represent the meanings of those words MH
so and there should be a mapping from
the word in the language to the meaning
of the word although it could be that
there are some meanings that are a
single meaning but cannot be represented
in less than five words in a given
language
true
what on Earth are those really
weird things in at the top oh I don't
know I mean it's the Legacy stuff from
from word net right we've we generally
clean yeah yeah I mean we've cleaned
those out of the the Alpha version and
the The Entity based version it's just
the that's the legacy of wordnet that
they had all this goofy stuff well I'm
sure that I me was one of the creators
of woodnet I'll be
disappointed I don't know let's find out
I'm just going to
look
um
well actually not oh I see
okay she still doesn't belong in word
data she does not belong in word data
she might have had a very interesting
and fine life but she respect for her
but
yeah
um okay so should we schedule the
followup let's and try to get this in
soon and let's talk through the the word
specific part because I would like to
move forward with figuring out what
we're doing here kind of right right on
the cusp of you know do we do we go in
and add a few hundred thousand more word
entities so we have something that
represents all these different inflected
forms because there's a lot we can do
programmatically there's some llm
assisted stuff that can help with this
we've been filling in know sense tags
for Words um with some llm manual
curation
tag teaming that's going well um but
there's a bunch of little things that we
want to just pin down so we can move
forward right well I think we need yes
okay let me let let's get that on the
schedule soon so we can keep going here
okay sounds good all right we should
probably wrap up for now and uh talk to
you all
soon see you
later